the other possibility I guess and that's
a peaceful divorce peaceful divorce I
like that you mentioned uh Donald Trump
you know it would be good if he came out
announced he was going to put on the
ballot secession for every state or
something of that effect yeah look you
know here's here's the thing that I
think everyone needs to kind of
understand is that this idea of
Independence or a shuffling of of the
political structure has been in the wind
for a long time look I've personally
been working on the Texas Independence
issue since August 24th 1996 right so
I've been at this a long time but what's
amazing is since this undercurrent has
been happening it's not just Texas right
Alaska has had an independence party
since the 80s uh the whole Joe Vogler
story is pretty pretty impressive it
should be a movie uh but there's you
know emerging Independence movements in
in California in New Hampshire in
Vermont a lot of other states I mean
we're hearing talk of flex it now uh but
the the bottom line here is simply this
the the movement toward the chef
shuffling of the political structure and
outright Independence is not new and
it's not rare and it's not unpopular
yeah I'm sharing a statistic with the
guys earlier that most people don't
realize there was a poll uh to survey
USA poll that dropped in the summer that
showed that support for Texas was at 66
percent of likely voters in Texas wow
and that's not an aberration right so
you roll it back to 2009 the research
2000 poll it was about 30 some odd
percent I like to joke that when we
founded the tnm in 2005 it was polling
in Singapore that's our organization the
Texas Nationals movement but you know
we've always polled higher than the
approval rating of the United States
Congress which polls somewhere right or
below above or below leprosy right I
mean they're not particularly popular
you'll get that later the leprosy thing
right but anyway
um you know the the whole thing is that
this has been a steady progression of
support a lot of it driven by a bunch of
on the ground work that we've done since
2005 but obviously a lot of it driven by
the deteriorating situation with the
federal government we're more more
people feel disconnected so the 66
percent was not an aberration you know
there was a
there was a pull down of five different
regions in the U.S they asked them
whether they supported their Regents
seceding from the union yeah and I
normalized so you have five different
region pollings Democrat Republican
independent I normalized for for state
population and and you know the numbers
and uh when you when you normalize 37.2
percent of people in the United States
want their region to secede well some
more so than others right uh in the
Midwest Independence the plurality wants
secession in the South it's the majority
with uh it's Republicans wanting
secession in California in the west
coast it's Democrats that want secession
so well look I mean that's the the
polling on this issue the mainstream
media anytime they decide to dig off
into the polling on this issue they do
something weird like that where let's
look at it by region instead of by state
right which is not the way that it works
it doesn't work by region every state as
a political entity would have the
ability to put it on the ballot and
withdraw right so 2014 during the time
of the Scottish independence referendum
wrote that Reuters episodes poll did
exactly the same thing and so they
lumped Texas in with the Southwest which
was New Mexico and Arizona and obviously
New Mexico is not a state that's going
to want to break away so they did that
to skew the numbers but we got a hold of
the crosstabs and the raw data and did
the same thing that's when that was the
first time we discovered that texit was
polling at 54 percent Republican half of
independent voters and 35 percent of
Democrats right that was the bombshell
but instead it was 35 percent of people
in the South southwest region want their
state to leave right it's garbage so
what do you do with that number
well uh pretty much what we do right so
there is a there is a process right
there is a process and um what I what I
tell people is look if you look overseas
right you you we've got plenty of
examples of Independence referenda
around the world uh and that's
ultimately where this is headed is to a
vote when people think of Texas they
need to think about what they saw in
Scotland in 2014 brexit a couple years
later we're going to put it on the
ballot and last uh actually last
legislative session in Texas we had the
Texas Independence referendum act
introduced by state representative Kyle
biederman that would have done just that
it would have allowed the voters to go
to the polls and look down at a ballot
and answer the question should the state
of Texas reassert its status as an
independent nation that ultimately is is
what people need to to do is they need
to be given the choice a good bit of the
reason that we've been able to build
support is because of how how we've been
talking about this issue to the people
this is what we ask them imagine right
now if if Texas or your state was
already a self-governing Nation right
you had control over your own border and
immigration policy your own military
you're on currency and monetary policy
you know you you had your own uh
military you had your own passports your
own embassies you had your own Olympic
team you had everything that 200 other
self-governing independent nations
around the world has okay fix that in
your mind and then ask yourself this
instead of talking about withdrawing
from the union imagine if you were
talking about whether or not your state
your self-governing independent nation
state should join the union knowing
everything you know about the federal
government right now would you vote to
join
hell no well it depends on him please
welcome you to the team if we were being
invaded by like cartels like literally
like a 10 000 man cartel army with maybe
they had bomb if they're dropping bombs
on cities like we'd have no choice but
to petition the United States to join
the union at that point for defense well
okay let's just let's just be clear that
any state that would be a self-governing
independent nation already would already
have control of its National Defense you
know down here let's let's be honest
you're talking about the cartels and
people ask that question about Texas all
the time we've got Boy Scout Troops that
are more well-armed than the cartels
okay in Texas I mean that's a bit of an
exaggeration but I think you get the
point the these issues that people bring
up about you know that sort of Safety
and Security understand that 200 other
countries around the world have already
figured this out right they already
defend them defend themselves from
Attack as a matter of fact in in the
particular instance as I talked about
the Border earlier part of the biggest
challenge that we have in Texas is the
fact that our border is Left unchecked
Right Where when you have sheriffs in
Texas saying that the federal government
has neglected securing the border to
such a point that the cartels are
effectively in control of the Rio Grande
River guess what uh we're already under
attack and the federal government is
doing nothing about it is it preventing
Texas from defending itself
well I think Texas could take that step
I mean you know we I've been very
critical of grow of Governor Greg Abbott
I know uh Chad was on the show not too
long ago and Chad I've talked about this
quite a bit it's been a pretty constant
refrain as we want the governor to call
an invasion to declare an invasion which
he allegedly did today right but he said
that he was invoking that Invasion
Clause under article 4 section 4 of the
U.S Constitution but he gave a laundry
list of things that Texas was in fact
already doing right you know escorting
illegal immigrants back to the border
which is effectively Catch and Release
right because they go immediately back
into Federal custody who then runs them
through the pipeline and ships them all
over the United States gives them Asylum
all those sorts of things you know
increase the gun boats down on the Rio
Grande river we already have those right
so he gave a big one why doesn't he
arrest the people who are traveling to
him well that includes that includes
purported uh people masquerading as law
enforcement well they they do that I
mean to a certain extent but not to the
number so you have to go back to when
you hear Greg Abbott talking about
operation Lone Star uh we kind of refer
to it as operation half measure right
because operation Lone Star started back
when I think Perry uh Governor Perry
uh started working on that issue uh and
he decided Well I'm going to increase
Department of Public Safety patrols 35
you know up to 30 miles in from the
border right so it wasn't Border
Protection it was we're going to run
traffic patrols to see if maybe we can
possibly catch some of these Smugglers
right and so Abbott's program has
effectively been to expand on that
program but it's a very it's not very
different at all uh you'll you'll hear
him say that he's put National Guard
down on the border and in fact he has
but so if they if if they uh catch some
illegal immigrants and then bring them
to the border and then a couple of guys
show up claiming they're with the
federal government and bring them back
in what does Texas do
say oh okay all right well so they get
turned over into Federal custody who's
they the the illegal immigrants so when
they are interdicted by the state they
get uh they get taken back to the border
which immediately puts them back into
Federal custody the federal government
will put them in detention centers or in
some cases put them up in hotels that
they rent with taxpayer money then those
illegal immigrants are processed out of
that facility handed over effectively to
ngos who take taxpayer money give them
funds and then uh ship them around
around the country so generally you'll
see that pipeline happen where they are
transferred from those detention
facilities to the airports in in Houston
or San Antonio they are lined up they're
given uh they're given cash payments in
most instances of your tax money
funneled through these ngos like
Catholic Charities they're giving it in
an envelope the coyotes come out of line
they take their cut they get on the on
the plane and get flown out to God only
knows where right and then the coyote
pops out of line goes back and runs the
whole gamut again and so the federal
government when we talk when we're
critical about the federal government On
the Border this is not just neglect
right this is intentional what's
happening down there on the border they
are facilitating this and our criticism
for governor Abbott has been he has not
taken strong enough measures look our
our organization has advocated for for
years and years and years what needs to
happen is rather than calling up the
National Guard Texas has a three branch
military called the Texas Military
Department two branches of International
Guard but one estate guard we've we've
advocated that Greg Abbott and and the
legislature should effectively shift
funds from the National Guard units in
the Texas Military Department fully fund
fully militarize the Texas state guard
and then declare an invasion and have
Governor Abbott as the
commander-in-chief of the Texas military
forces deploy them down to supporter
protection force and if the federal
government didn't like it they could go
pound sand and the big fear is on their
part is that it will cause a
constitutional crisis well so what I
don't care about a constitutional crisis
I have a border crisis and an invasion
that's happening that any Sovereign
self-governing independent nation could
take care of but we're not allowed to
but that is one of the reasons that
people are clamoring to have taxes
because self-governing independent
nations get to take care of them let me
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time